Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast farm by day, October,
October 2nd oh my God. Get
Out. You fucking Barracuda,
dude. It's a fucking fall.
It's officially the fall,
isn't it? Lovely. Honda's
leaves turning different colors,
falling off the trees and
crunching under your feet.
Halloween comes and then Thanksgiving
and it'll be a good 75 80 degrees with a
whatever, but the oceans rising, but
whatever's going be very interesting.
It's going to be very interesting.
False. I feel coming up.
Oh, do you feel it, bill?
Was this your own idea?
Did you stick your head out the window
and assess it or did you listen to a
bunch of Shit on TV? All
right, you got me. You got me.
But it is the fall, the falls,
one of my favorite seasons,
what I loved about the fall was the
beginning of the school year and I
absolutely love school. I just, when I
was a child, I just, I crave knowledge.
I don't know what it was like.
Of course the other kids wanted
to go outside and play and gaging
contests of sport, but not me now. I just
wanted to curl up in the corner disk,
couldn't just, my mother just
couldn't get me enough books.
I know. I was obviously, um, it
was obviously in a non truth.
None of that was true.
Uh,
what I liked about the fall was I
got new clothes for school, you know,
which back then was you got your hand
me downs from your brother and you got a
new pair of sneakers. All right. And uh,
they were new until that first time it
fucking rained or something happened and
then they would just, you know, that was
it. And those, we use sneakers for a year.
You wore sneakers for a year.
Your mother bought him like a half
size or a full size too big dependent.
We know she was trying to gauge,
you know,
when your balls we're going to drop to
considering how big your feet we're going
to be. Right. Um, it was
one of those, you know,
one of those things back then there
was like nine grades all in one class,
not fucking with you.
Um,
I liked the new sneakers in
the new clothes and whatever
hand be down shit that
I got from my older brother. And then, uh,
and then it was football and then also
was starting to get cold so I didn't have
to deal with any more.
Do I look at why you fucking legs are,
I didn't have to deal with that with
the summer and empty. We'll sunburns.
I liked it. It was more of
a fucking winter guy. Um,
but other than that,
everything else sucked.
I fucking arc 180 days of school to go.
Can you believe that?
Used to think that that was hard and
he actually used to fuck up in school.
If you're like me, I always
look back. It's just like,
why don't I just come home?
Why not just pay attention,
come home and just do my homework.
I could've gone to like a
really good college. Like,
and to me a good college is, it has, it
has a sports program that I can follow.
It's division one and you know,
they battled for fucking at
least to win their conference.
You know what I mean?
I don't fucking,
okay.
I Dunno. I, I don't fucking like
these college you should go to where
everybody is. I don't know what it is.
Like take Vanderbilt
in the SEC by the way.
Who played a hell of a fucking
game this weekend? Right?
Scared the shit out of Florida.
Um,
I always thought that, you know, I always,
I always assumed that that school sucked
because their football team was no good
for so long.
Now they're actually halfway decent.
But I judge schools by how
good their sports program is.
And you know, there's a lot of people on
real sports are one of those shows that,
you know,
everybody wears suits and for some
reason they have a pen but they're never
really writing, you know, those shows that
take it really seriously. And then they,
what does that silly little Lucille,
the educational system that people
judge a school by their sports programs?
Well, no, this you fucking
pencil pushing nerd.
There would be no campus without sports.
Okay.
On a thousand fucking fractal
drops like me fill a stadium.
That money goes right back
into the school, doesn't it?
God knows it's not paying the players.
All right.
And that's why when you go to
the University of Michigan,
it's its own fucking city. It's not
because of the science department.
Well, the engineers that know
how to build the buildings,
it's cause the big blue down the fucking
street [inaudible] pulling 100 400,
510,000 people a Goddamn game.
That's what pays for it.
You know? Even if it's not all
that money, the level of attention.
And that makes people all
around the world, you know? No.
That song hail to the victors.
Valliant hail to the victors.
Fucking get on a raft.
Get over here and go to that school.
Right. Isn't that how it goes?
I don't know. MMM. I don't know.
What the fuck was I talking about? Why I
like the fall? Yeah. I would've fucked in.
I study
so fucking stupid.
I can't believe. I can't imagine if I
actually understood calculus, what my,
what my world would be like right now
by just took the time to fuck.
I mean it's not like they just
dumped it all on you the first day.
Yeah.
I forget when I stopped paying attention
somewhere around seventh grade I just
was like, Eh, I'm just not into this.
MMM.
Oh my God.
I could have studied and then I could
do one of those extra curricular things
and got like a scholarship,
you know,
participated in a bunch of other shit than
I would have had that all flushed out.
I see you're on the debating team.
You're on the swimming team and I'll
let shit remember those fucking kids.
The kid next to you. His
locker was like neat, you know?
And it wasn't all dented and shit.
Fucking always had his homework
wear like sweaters, you know,
you just be looking at him
like kind of fun as fuck does.
This person is like my age and
they have their shit that together
always at a thousand papers falling
out of my fucking, it just was a mess.
And every year I'd be like, okay,
this year I'm going to study,
I'm going to fucking am I
drawn all over my books.
I'm going to pay attention. I'm going to
try and get all A's and B's. That's all.
That's all I wanted to do and I just,
I couldn't do it.
I put up a good fight through about,
I get to about September 10th
then I get like that
first fucking c, c, c,
c. What's that? What's that
a reference to? Speaking of
moving, let movie lines. Si.
Si,
Si.
Was it summer rentals for summer school
that it was the guy who's been on TV for
40 years but never does interviews,
so people kind of Mark Harmon is that
his name? Was that guy like chainsaws,
some shit.
Then of course they made the Latino girl
pregnant cause you could still do that
back then.
Can't do that now you get called out on,
they would never do that now.
Now they would make the white guy pregnant
to show that that progressive,
that's how it would work.
You know what I mean?
There's nothing wrong with having
a Latino woman to be pregnant,
but when she's the only
Latino in the fucking movie,
that's when it becomes a problem.
Oh.
So she's going to summer school and
she's knocked up and she's dressed like
fucking zebra man and
heavy metal parking lot.
Do you know?
I'd never seen that.
I thought that was an entire fucking
movie and ice for years. I was like,
I got to get around to watch and heavy
metal parking lot. I never fucking saw it.
And finally somebody referenced
it again. Um, oh, I know why.
Dean del Ray from the let there be talk
all things, comedy network podcast.
He sent me a link and one
of Judas Priest's guitarist,
uh, who the, those KK downing and Glen
[inaudible], Glen Tipton, he bought,
I hope I'm saying his name right.
He bought a fucking Porsche in 1985 or
86 he went to the factory when he was on
tour and that's back when they made
them. Hey, there was hand built,
none of this robot shit.
None of this outsourcing it to fucking
whatever the fuck they do it now. Um,
they were hand built.
Okay.
By the same people that
brought you audio tape
and World War One and World War
Two. All right. It was fucking,
they were hand fucking built.
It's right at the same people brought
you October fest and the Holocaust,
you know what I mean? They're there.
They're all over the map over there.
That's why Germany is
still such a scary country.
It's like what's going
to happen over here?
Are we all going to get drink beers and
get shit faced or are you guys going to
try and take over the world again?
You know,
that's what's on their weather channel
as a monitor.
All the psychos over there.
What are the, what is,
what does the general population planning
right now or possibly a small group of
really motivated people
within Deutschland.
So anyways,
I had never seen heavy metal parking lot.
I thought it was a full movie. So I sit
down to watch it right out of the gate.
I love it.
Cause the concerts at the cap center.
And that's where I used to
watch the, uh, you know,
whenever the Bruins used to play,
when they'd go down and play the capitols.
And they had rod lang way look like my
math teacher back in the day that my math
teacher was a dead fucking ringer.
Flunked his class two fucking
years in a row was two summers.
I'll never get back.
Actually my senior year I didn't fucking
go to summer school was like, well,
what's the point? I can't get into a
school that has a good foot, you know,
football program or basketball program.
I don't know, sports here, so fuck it.
Um, anyways, what the fuck am I talking
about? Yeah. So I'm watching this thing.
So they had the cap center,
which I never really saw what it looked
like because they never really showed
the outside that I can remember.
They just be abroads that I,
they would camp center
Berry Peterson leading the league with
40 some goals a great year. He had,
um, and we traded in my belief. Um,
so I go to watch this fucking thing
and uh, I've gotta be honest with you.
Like the memories that came flying back,
first of all,
my first concert ever was Judas
priest with dock and opening up.
Of course it was dark and they
fucking open for everybody.
Day Open for everybody in Tesla opened
for fucking and Cinderella opened for
fucking everybody.
MMM.
That was my first on the Turbo Lover Tour.
Right.
And I guess I found out all these years
later that that Judas priest Guy Glen
Tipton or whatever,
but a fucking Porsche that was a turbo
and he loved it so much that he's fucking,
you know, was inspired to write a song
and then a rob Halford took it in whatever
direction he wanted to take it in. You
know that we remember that song. Huh?
Your turbo lava make no sense.
Right?
You won't see me
then.
Yeah.
Uh,
Geo feel me.
Oh, like crazy music. Right. Um,
I saw them on that tour. So anyway,
so I watched that heavy metal, uh,
parking lot and um,
I was fucking great.
That's exactly, I mean, to have a
fucking fill now. I know way, way,
way past the whole, everybody knows
that by now we have a film that thank,
thank you so much for filming that.
I do.
The first time I ever saw anybody do blow,
I went to an ACDC concert.
I remember I pull up my big
stupid red fucking hair. Right.
You know, and I can't grow at long. My
hair just grew out so I, I was like,
I missed it man. I should have come
up in the 70s I would have been fine.
We'd have been rocking that Bernie
from room to 22 but you know,
everybody kind of had their shit.
You know,
I don't know what the fuck it was in the
80s wasn't short, but it wasn't long.
It was bright before the mullets
feathered, everything was feathered.
Fairfox it was so hot. Even the guys
tried to have their hair let curse. Right.
That's what was going on. And
me, I was just like, you know,
I was a man without a spot, without a
fucking country. So I would pull up,
you know,
not a whisker on my face.
I fucking pull up my
stupid fucking looking.
Like I swear to God looking
like a giant opie Taylor and a,
and I was totally into the music,
but I just look like a fucking freak,
you know, I should've grown
my, I go actually I couldn't
grow my house assessed,
should at least go on the Malakai route
and just been drunk enough and just got
out of the car and screamed Outlander
and then everybody will left me own loan.
I remember I pulled up to the ACDC thing
and this fucking guy was doing blow and
he had a Toyota pickup truck rusted out.
Of course back then
everything fucking rusted,
especially the Toyota Hunks and hunks of
shit. But the engines would never die.
Right?
You'd be driving down the street.
You could literally see the
fucking engine still working.
So this guy gets out of the car
and I'm like looking at him like I
know we liked the same kind of music,
but we are not the same person.
I remember he was fucking, yeah,
this blond hair look,
cut his own hair.
It was like some like a
fucked up page boy haircut
and like a perm all at the same time.
And like he turned around and through the
line and then fucking came right up to
my window as I pulled up looking
like a fucking, like, I don't know,
I felt like I was on one of those zoos
where the animals aren't in a cage,
you know, he just came up and he was
like, yeah. And I was kinda like, hey man.
Fortunately I was with somebody else. I
think that we were listening to who made,
who would a very respectable volume.
Um, yeah, that was the, who made,
who want in loudness,
opened up a Japanese heavy metal band.
Um, I dunno what the fuck I'm
talking about here. Let's, let's,
let's get into the podcast. I'm
just sort of meandering here. Um,
why don't we talk a little bit
of NFL football. We'd like,
we've got to talk college first. All
right. So when I watched, I watched, uh,
I watched Texas tech
against, um, Oklahoma state.
What a fucking great game that was. And
what an atmosphere out there in Lubbock,
Texas. I got to go a Texas tech gay
man. So I was actually out there.
I was looking up theaters to see
if they had a little stutter.
I could play maybe next year, whatever,
during football season, you know,
anybody can go to Dallas.
Right.
I've already been to Texas A and M
and I've been to the Texas longhorns.
The next big program is Texas Tech.
Right.
Of course they'll give
you shit at Baylor or Smu.
They never recovered from
the fucking death penalty.
But what else they got out
there? I think that's it. So, um,
I was rooting for Texas
tech cause I know I just,
just cause they were the underdog,
but it's such a fucking great game.
And I was flipping back and forth,
you know, my adopted college team,
Lsu fucking tigers, you know,
we lost again, but you know,
we lost to the Trojan. So that's okay.
You know, that's how I say it to people.
You know, we, we lost
this week to the Trojans.
I thought USC last two.
All they did.
I was talking about the Troy Trojans
from the very formidable sun belt
conference.
I was embarrassed as a new Lsu fan.
I became an Lsu fan about
nine years ago and as a, uh,
adopted team to see all those fucking
people leave the fucking stadium emptied
out with eight minutes to go. All right.
Granted they needed three scores, but uh,
I, I didn't like that at
all. I hate seeing that.
And then I was at that point just rooting
that they came back and one just so
all those fucking cunts would have to
lie on Monday and see that they were part
of the 40 people that still stuck around.
But um,
I'm trying to think what
was worse watching Lsu lose
to Troy or the Troy Trojans
helmets, you know, you know,
everything has to look like fucking,
I don't know.
You know,
that you don't let that Awful Candy at
movie theaters that they only sell it at
movie theaters,
whatever those fucking things are.
I don't mean gummy bears don't have a good
friend of mine that loves gummy bears,
Guy Friend. It just, I dunno, it just, it
almost fucks up our friendship, you know,
like when, when he's kind
of bugging me, whatever,
I just kind of think every once in once
it gets fucking guy likes gummy bears.
I'll do what? I love going to movies,
you know, I fucking love going to movies.
I take my kids, you know,
get a box of gummy bears,
gummy bears. Um, yeah,
the fucking Oregon ducks. All
right. Those green and yellow cons,
they fucked it up for everybody.
They were the first ones to put the disco
ball in their head and now everybody's
doing it. I'm calling it right now.
Those fucking things are going to look,
they're going to look fucking ridiculous
in years to come. People will be like,
what in the Fi's that electric is that
thing like plugged in or some shit?
Some of them are cool. I guess. I don't
know what, but I, I love how the MLB,
this year they went back to the,
uh,
like they went to like this non gloss
matte color on the batting helmets say
look fucking mean as hell,
man. I'm meeting as hell, man.
Um, so anyways, that's what
the fuck I watched. And um,
then I watch pro football today or
[inaudible]
Jay, Jay ash, the New England patriots
with their second loss of the year.
Um, pardon me, joys that they lost twice
because it keeps all the fucking price.
It'd be nice to have a nice
fucking anticipation free a season,
you know?
And when you're two and two,
God knows nobody's fucking looking at
you now. Uh, how about that defense? Huh?
The fuck I'll tell you.
I'll tell you right now,
if you want to score 30 points,
you got to go to new wig. Like,
okay,
I'm trying to,
I should look this up like we gave up,
I think we gave up 75 points in the first
two games and then we added another 30
today. Is that what happened?
Let's look at the Patriots here.
Let's look at this sad,
sad tale and I can't figure
out what the fuck is going on.
I mean,
how many yards have we given up this
year on just like blown coverages that
fucking fake screen pass.
Like the entire defense
on that side bites on it.
You know, if we look at our
corners and our safety's,
it's still butler Chung McCourty.
Those guys have been
playing together for years.
I don't know how long we've had the
Gilmore Guy, but I like that guy.
That guy hits hardy knock somebody out
of the game. He had another good hit,
you know, bullshit hands to the
face and then a brutal one. But a,
we shouldn't have been in that
situation to begin with. But, um,
our offense is fine me course.
I would love if our offensive line could
give them a little Brady a little more
time. Um, he's definitely taken too many
hits, but we're still scoring points.
But our defense, Jesus Christ,
not really stopping the run,
not really getting pressure on the
quarterback blown fucking coverages.
But, uh, I just feel like the blown
coverage, is that something that you know,
met Patricia can work on,
right.
He can get those guys like three of
the four of them. It's just like,
you guys want to fucking
Superbowl last year. I'm not,
I don't know all the patriots,
so I don't know when Gail Morgan
on the fucking team. Um, all right,
let's look at Patriot's here.
patriots.com I should have gone schedule,
right? Is that what I should've done?
This is going to take for fucking ever
patriots schedule. All right, here we go.
Patriots schedule.
They're going to go download
the schedule when, okay,
so we let up 42 points the first week.
Then we were on the road,
only let up 20.
Then we let up 33 and we let up 33 again.
Those are all at fucking up.
No, two of those were home.
Three of those weren't home.
Jesus fucking Christ. All right.
33 36 42 I think.
I Dunno,
I just glance at those numbers.
Wait,
(333) 034-0220 thank God for the 20.
All right.
42 and 20 is 62 so that's 31.
So we're averaging like
fucking, I dunno, 30 I guess.
32 points a fucking game.
Yeah. Yeah. Tie, right? No,
you're not going to go far in the
fucking playoffs. Um, by the way,
my fucking football pick came in.
I called it the fucking giants
get in three against Tampa Bay.
Dude, I fucking called it. I told you.
Yeah,
granted, the giants didn't fucking
win, but they only lost by two. Um,
and as a Patriot Fan,
I hate that the giants are owned four
more so than I hate the fact that we're
two and two because I wanted
to play the giants again.
The Superbowl to fucking beat those
bastards one time. Where you what?
Why don't we, we got nothing to lose.
The giants got everything to lose.
They've got shit talking rights
right now. You just got to say, hey,
you guys fucking owners. Right? By the
way, somebody tweeted like to do it.
When was the last time you guys even
fucking beat us? I went to a home game.
Own away game. I'm sorry, giants.
We fucking beat you up. Uh, I dunno.
The last time we played you in the
regular season in your fucking house,
you can't, it's fucking guys bragging
about preseason games. It's like,
dude, you want to super bowls?
That's all you give a fuck about. Um,
so anyways, uh, so that's my one pick.
So now I'm going to make another
pick on Thursday. All right, Abby.
Every Thursday I'm going to do my NFL
pick of the week. Now what is what?
You have to thank for your
fucking degenerate Gambler,
you know good and God damn well,
I have just as much chance with the
information that I'm using of picking a
winner as a housewife who doesn't
watch a game. Okay? So this first week,
I'm not going to say it was dumb luck.
I was going on fucking how many points
the giants scored against the eagles.
I know they scored him late and then Eli
Manny, who's ripped my heart out twice,
showed it to me and then very politely
aided and didn't get any blood on his
doctors, right? I was like, there's
no fucking way that these guys,
and I thought that they want to come away
with a win. I did Buccaneers. Look, Greg,
God bless him by the way. Who the fuck is
this? Ron Funches guy on the, on the, uh,
on, uh, Carolina fucking panthers.
Guy was killing us all day long.
I was, I don't pray for injuries,
but when his leg cramped up, I was like,
thank God. Then he came back out again,
caught another first down second.
We get that fucking Guy Outta here.
Um, so anyways, uh, that's
what I was basing it on.
So I'm going to pick another
one on Thursday and then
you the degenerate gambler.
You gotta be wondering,
we'll all freckles.
Will he get lucky two weeks in a row?
Because now I'm in your
head cause I won last week.
This is like playing roulette, like
going right. The last time was black.
Is it going to be another black
or is it going to be a red?
Do I sit out this week?
See if it goes to blacks in a row,
then I know it's going to be red.
All right. No, it was red this week.
I'm a goddamn ginger. All right.
Remember that Guy Fucking,
he didn't pay his taxes. Always
been on black. Always been on red.
Um,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
that might be the Photoshop of this week.
That's too fucking easy, right?
That's a movie poster right there.
Always bet on red.
I don't know who's playing next week.
So how about those fucking La Ramps,
not your same old rams.
Fucking winning win and win and beat the
Dallas fucking cowboys. Jesus Christ.
They're gonna have their fucking heads
in a noose out there. Um, all right,
well let's get down to it. Oh, Billy.
Fucking booze back his back.
I fell off the wagon.
I couldn't do it. I'm fucking with
you. I'm still on the fucking wagon.
I went to Vegas and I passed that test.
I was at the, uh, the Monte Carlo,
not the race.
The fucking casino stayed over at the
MGM Grand Cause they're doing some,
uh, construction, I
guess on the Monte Carlo.
So they had me across the street and uh,
oh my God, what a fucking,
that way there's, there's
no better people watching.
Then when you go to Vegas, Holy
Shit. I went down to the pool. Yes.
I went down to the pool. I was working
with partner. He's an Italian guy.
He actually has pigments. So he wanted
to go down in the polls. I had fucking,
I'm not going to stay in
the room the whole time.
So I go down to the Goddamn pool dude.
And it was like right as the sun
had already started to go down,
was on the other side of the casino.
So it really wasn't any sun on the water.
So there was maybe five or six young
people there and everybody else was my
generation or older and Holy Shit,
I know this is a hacky topic.
I know this is,
but thank God I never got a tattoo.
Thank fucking Christ.
If you saw these fucking people,
and they're my age man,
49 years old, no shirt on.
All these fucking chicks with
their ankles, sorority tattoos,
telling kids what to do with tattoos,
you know what I mean?
And then that good.
That's what kills me about the tattoo
becoming mainstream was the incredible
like lack of research
that most people did.
Their total lack of
respect for the art form
and the complete lack of
respect for themselves
to go out and try to actually
find somebody good at it.
I gotta tell you,
I must've seen 500 fucking tattoos on
about a hundred different people down
there at the pool.
Everybody just tatted up,
shit show man boobs are
just peck sag and down.
You know, women, you always gotta
give a pass because they, they have,
they have to bear children.
All right,
but guys, man, there's no fucking
reason. You just keep doing the pushups.
Yeah,
keep the chest high and tight with the
fuck are you doing lay off the pizza and
the boots.
She fucking guys just walking around
this saggy chess and the fucking tribal
band,
the tramp stamps,
those sorority ankle tattoos.
Just fucking horrific.
I went down there and
was just sitting there,
just reminded of my own mortality
going like, Jesus Christ.
I really want to fucking act like I'm
above these people, but like, you know,
smartest fucking thing I that I,
I didn't do was I never got a tattoo.
Jesus fucking Christ. Thank
Christ. I never did it. You know,
I like it used to be back
in the, you know, cause look
at me. I'm not a tattoo guy.
All right,
Tattoo. They, they, they
got to go back to bad asses.
You know what I mean?
Guys in biker gangs or in prison or like
chicks who not a shoot pool where the
leather pants,
right.
Hey,
I'm out of my fucking mind.
So we went down there and we
just looked at that fucking
see a humanity and then this guy just
comes out just screaming about how he lost
20 grand and he had a big grin on his
face. He goes, throw me in the pool.
I can't swim. Maybe I'll
drown. I just lost 20 grand.
I just lost 20 grand in there.
And I looked down and was like,
that fucking guy doesn't have 20 grand.
There's no fucking way. He's got 20 grand.
And who fucker walks ease?
He's just acting like he's a big shot,
right there may be dead. I
have no fucking idea. So, um,
and we went over,
we did the show and after the show we
sat out by this giant air conditioning
duck behind a wall on a picnic table
and smoke cigars. And it was great.
And I didn't participate at
all in the Vegas Shenanigans.
I knew enough when I walked through
the lobby and I saw the people,
all the young people, I was
like, this is their time.
Don't be the creepy guy hanging around,
ruining it, get the fuck outta here.
So I went back over to the MGM,
walked back and a,
I got back probably about 1230 at night
and I was at first wave of women that
had had enough, you know, two out of
three of them are walking barefoot,
carrying their horse horseshoes,
right?
What happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas and they just said dirty feet,
just walk into the f
with a giant fucking drink.
And I was glad that I stayed.
I did stay out of that and I didn't booze,
although I did smoke a fucking cigar
and a Kinda did it on an empty stomach.
And I got admit I was a little fucking
nauseous cause it was this giant Cuban.
And the next day we took the helicopter
out and back and on the way back,
those like a 17 to 30 knot wind,
depending on what altitude we were until
we really got down low flying over the
15,
it got down to like nine knots and we
kind of getting pushed around a little bit
up there. And that was a couple
times I was like, oh my God,
feeling a little nauseous up here.
You know,
that's not what you want to see from
your pilot asking for a puke bag. I mean,
the most comforting thing he could say
at that point, you know, it's all right.
It's all right. I, I drank last night,
so, um, anyways, but I gotta
tell you, man, flying out there,
taking the helicopter and going
over the mode. Javvi desert.
MMM.
Was it was, it was fucking incredible.
The desert is so, it's like beautiful,
terrifying, boiling, hot and
freezing all at the same time.
It's just fucking, I swear to
God, I don't know why. You know,
what's something that people
thought we faked the moon landing.
That's probably where they went, right?
They probably just went out to the desert.
You know it's a lot of mountains though.
I don't think they faked it, man.
I think they going, I think they got
up there. I have it gives a fuck.
Maybe they didn't. There's so much
shit for me to fucking babble about.
Do you guys watch the Formula One at all?
Huh?
Anybody see it than
anybody? She ate it all. Uh,
what do I have it here?
It gets to the fucking standings.
I know. What's his
face? One from red bull.
Red Bull had to fucking
cars and I can now,
I always want to say I always fuck up
that guy's name. The fuck is his name.
Who wanted this? Who won the
race today? The fuck's his name.
What is his name?
Max For stappen once I think Sebastian
Vettel I can't think Verstappen cause
that v like my brain can only handle one
v word a minute or the same letter I'm
telling you I have, I don't know
what the fuck my deal is. Um,
but this is the first race that
I saw with Lewis Hamilton or,
or, uh, Valtteri Botox
in the Mercedes teams.
One of what? Either one of them, if they,
if they're in first fucking
place going into the turn,
the Mercedes cars are just too goddamn
good. Maybe a Ferrari can run him down.
I've never fucking seen it, but
red bull, this was their day.
This was their track.
They were amazing.
Lewis Hamilton got into fucking the first,
it was the first person
that came out in the lead.
I can't even talk this fucking
pockets. I apologize. Um,
came onto the first turn in the lead
and as far as my year and a half of
watching this shit,
that means you're going to win the race,
especially if your number
Sadie's and, um, for staff.
And actually came right up on him and went
right around them like it was nothing.
And then opened up like an eight,
nine second lead on them. I have,
I've never seen that. I'm a Mercedes
humbled like that by red bull.
So congratulations. Then Daniel
Ricardo came in third place and, uh,
Lewis Hamilton fucking steady, steady
Eddie there, still got second place.
He's got 281 fucking point.
Sebastian Vettel for whatever
fucking reason. Ferrari.
I don't know what they're doing.
My daughter had her first cold man,
so I was kind of watching her.
So I missed the beginning.
All of the sudden Kimmy raking it at some
going on with his turbo and he didn't
even fucking drive.
And Sebastian Vettel was way in the back,
so I'm going to guess,
uh,
you the fucked up during the time trials
and got some sort of penalty or they
had to switch out a gearbox.
There's some shit that puts
you at the back of the race.
You're only allowed to use so many parts,
somebody engines or something
like that throughout the season.
So he was all the way in the back.
He was able to work himself all
the way up to fourth place, um,
which was really impressive.
Uh, but now he is, be as,
what does he got? He's 34
fucking points. I mean,
I don't think that they'd make it
up after that debacle in Singapore,
that absolute fucking three
stooges fucking debacle.
I don't think that they make it up,
but it was very exciting as a new fan
of Formula One to actually see somebody
enforced first place and get past actually
see a Mercedes Benz in first place
and get past it gave me hope that
Formula One can be more like that.
Um, the way moto GP is.
All right. Um, anyways,
let's get to some of the reads
here for the week. Uh, some of the,
actually some of the advertising and
shall we, uh, have a popup, where is it?
Ah, look who's here. Pro
Flowers. Oh No, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
Did I cut that off?
This podcast? It just fucking blows. What
am I doing today? Oh look, goes here,
me and Da. That Oto beyond beyond
ease. Bill can't fucking read to do,
to do beyond these beyond ease.
Mass is starting to bleed,
but they got a got fucking silk
down by my tanked and my balls.
Who fucking cares if I'm bleeding
from the yard? She's still that stuff.
That's just disgusting.
You already know me.
Undies makes the most comfortable
underwear in the world.
If underwear isn't your thing,
man,
we're excited to announce that
me undies socks are finally here.
Be ready for work, play and everything
in between with the new me undies socks.
If you thought your balls felt good,
if you thought your balls thanked
you every week, wait to see you here.
What your toe say Mandy socks are now
available now and he socks are spun from
premium materials making their socks
the best you can get for your feet.
Talk about why me undies is the best
underwear and socks you will ever own.
Well they pay me to say so and a,
I have a daughter and she wants to go to
college one day and who knows how long
I sell tickets so I might as well say
that these guys have the best underwear
and socks beyond.
These will be the most comfortable pair
of underwear and now socks you will ever
own.
Exclusive offer right now beyond these
has an exclusive offer just for our
listeners and whoever
else they advertise with.
Get 20% off your first
order and free shipping.
BMDS is so sure you will love
their underwear and socks.
They give you a 100% I just pictured
somebody taking s, you know,
someone dries himself off with the towel
and they dry off there under carriage.
Just doing that with the sox
during the commercial going,
oh my God,
they feel amazing.
You just zoom in and zooming
out really quickly, you know,
to get that effect so you can't really
see the junk. You just see. See the sock,
right, and it's so fucking weird
that the millennials buy it.
Why don't we give millennials so
much shit? You know what I mean?
My generation should.
They should give people a,
the generation older than
me sh shit for raising them.
Is that right? I Dunno. Right now,
Mandy's has an exclusive offer just for
our listeners be entities is so sure
you'll love their underwear and socks.
They will give you a 100% satisfaction
guarantee. Simply order a pair.
If you don't like it, get a full
refund. This is a no brainer.
20% off free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee.
What are you waiting for him?
Yeah,
and he's dot com slash [inaudible] dot
com slash bar oh pro flowers just in time
for Halloween.
Um,
if you know any of those people
who are, you know, you know,
who are obsessed with fall,
things like pumpkin spice
lattes and scented candles,
pro flowers has the perfect gift.
It's called the ass vase.
You take a fucking long stem rose.
No,
a long lasting bouquet in
their favorite fall colors.
Their bestselling cinnamon fighter.
Roses are a great option for a birthday,
an anniversary,
any fall occasion or go with one of the
classics like 100 autumn blooms are a
dozen autumn roses.
Well,
I don't understand what don't fuck buys
flowers in, in October. It's the end.
Don't they die this time of year?
You buy them in the spring
hundred autumn balloons?
Well when they fucking, they turn
colors cause they can't breathe anymore.
You can't lose because no matter
which bouquet bouquet you send,
my listeners get 20% off
of any of the pro flowers.
Unique bouquets for $29 a more.
Is this where you get you
buy like that fucking,
it looks like something you'd yell
through, but it's really, it's made,
it's made like a basket weaving class
and there's a bunch of shit fallen out of
it. Usually it's squash. Um,
pro flowers bouquets are guaranteed to
stay fresh for at least seven days or
your money back and you
control the delivery date.
Pro Flowers gives you more bloom for
your buck. Big beautiful flowers.
More stems for your money
and long lasting freshness.
To get 20% off all the
bouquets for $29 and more,
go to pro flowers and use my code.
Burb Gurr. That's pro flowers.com.
Code name Burr.
What is that fucking thing called?
Let's do a search here.
Thanksgiving
horn thing.
Basket.
Yeah.
Squash.
See if this gets anything.
Bam.
A cornucopia.
It's a cornucopia basket. Look at that.
I nailed it. Thanksgiving horn thing.
Basket squash got me there.
All right.
Dawlish Dollar Shave Club, do you? Uh,
what you might not know is that dollar
shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in
the bathroom. Body Wash, shampoo,
Hair Gel, lip balm, herpes medicine,
everything at the store,
the crab comb at the store.
There are too many options.
And you can't tell the difference between
any of them if this a brush or is this
for my taint? Why is it always
go to the tank? I don't know. Uh,
then if you have any questions,
the clerk usually doesn't know the
difference either or can't really help you
since they are not an expert
on the products or maybe
they just have one person
working there, like my experience
and fucking cvs and Dwayne Reed,
they run a skeleton shift in the
middle of the fucking day. Uh,
now you don't have to step foot in a
store to get high quality to get a high
quality shave and grooming products.
A dollar shave club delivers them
right to your door. Pube tremors.
There's something else.
This is like the family feud named
something you'd find in a bathroom.
Johnson family.
Uh,
pube tremors show me [inaudible]
now we'd like the fourth answer
and everybody claps, you
know, and as they go,
like the authority and the intelligence
slowly starts to drop. You know,
maybe if they have an artist in the family
that lasts family members. All right,
but when they get down to that last
person, who else do we fucking bring?
You know? Um, anyways, where
am I as a, for a limited time,
dollar shave club is basically
giving away their shit.
Shower shave started set to new members
for only $5 to start a set features the
executive razor and three trial size
versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean.
I'm so fresh and so clean.
In your first box you will
receive their shave butter,
bodywash and one wipe Charlies.
Oh Cherry.
But wipes one wipe Charlie, but wipes. Um,
I've never used those one wipe and you
get it all. I don't know about that.
I don't know about that.
You will also receive
even like the cocaine shits,
the coke shits I always hear about because
they've been cut with laxative. Um,
that should be the test on the commercial
when they do the one white but Sha one
wipe Charlies. But shipe
but wipes. I just, I didn't,
why can't talk today? Um, you also
receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium,
weighty handle and full
cassette of cartridges.
Can I give you guys advice on a safety
razor? When you have a weighted handle?
Do not pull it across your face.
Hold it lightly and let gravity
with the weight of the handle.
Bring it down across your face. If
you don't, you're gonna cut yourself.
You will also receive their executive
razor, which includes Irish,
said that at after the first box.
Replacement cartridges are sent
for only a few bucks a month.
This offers exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar.
Uh,
that's dollar shave
club.com/bart Dollar Shave
club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from
face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There's no better time to try the
club. All right. I swear to God,
this is the last one. And I love
stamps.com because they know I can't read.
So they always make it nice and quick.
stamps.com everybody stamps
save you time and money,
which you can use to grow your
business or stare at your balls.
I can mail any letter and package just
using my computer and my printer and the
mailman comes and picks it up. She's
actually a lady and she's really offended.
Avoid the hassle of the post office
and mail everything from the postcards,
from postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes
online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments. Click print mail
and you're done. Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes,
right.
Just like the whore up the street.
It never the whores legs up the street,
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience. 24,
seven keyboard slash.
Descriptors. Convenient, easy,
reliable and flexible.
Just like the whore up the street.
I use stamps.com because include
your personal recommendation. Um,
I had a baby tooth left in my head
and it finally fell out in. I, uh,
use stamps.com to mail it back to my
mother when she sent me a quarter.
And right now,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstampsdotcomenterburrstamps.com
. Never go to the post
office again. All right.
Is that it? Is that it
for the reading? Um,
what else did I want to talk about
that I handle everything I think I did.
By the way,
I'm going to be in a Saint Petersburg,
Florida at the Mahaffey theater.
They added a late show this Friday night.
It's going to be me.
Uh,
Rosebowl Tailgate Legend,
Aka the,
uh, the crown royal kid, Joe Barton.
Nick. That's his new nickname,
the crown royal kid. He just got
signed to a three year deal. Um,
Paul Versey, Paul Dude, I called it
Versie. Whatever you do, do not bring up.
That is giants or Owen for.
Okay. He's very sensitive.
We're going to be down there.
Uh,
and Thursday night I'm going to
the Patriots for as Tampa game.
I'm going to be respectful.
I'm not wearing my patriots gear because
I don't listen to everybody giving me
shit. I don't need all that shit.
Even if we wanted to feed it,
I still wouldn't wear it. I, I've
learned, I just, I just go there.
I silently rude from my fucking team
of Tampa winds. I say congratulations.
Who gives a fuck?
This is the last NFL team that
I need to see a home game of.
And then I'll have gone to
all the baseball and all the,
all the football at a professional level.
And uh,
in my world of doing horrible in
school and going to colleges, uh,
numerous colleges during my
college career, none of which, oh,
I went to NC state for my
first, my freshman year, um,
sort of was in the off campus program.
I literally fucking drove into the
library and watch the classes on cassette
tape. Like I had some sort
of fucking terminal disease.
That was my first semester and
second semester I had two classes,
both of which I flunked because by then
I decided I didn't want to be in North
Carolina, so I sorta went there. Um,
this is back when NC state wolf pack
had like a Chucky Brown and Charles,
I think it was Charles Shackleford,
I believe they still had
grass seats in the end zone.
I went to a Carolina a state game there.
Then I went to a couple other
schools, uh, ended up at Emerson. Um,
Emerson, I don't even know
what I fucking mascot is.
I have no idea what it is. Uh, anyways,
it's like a final draft
software or some shit. Um,
the fuck am I talking about?
Yes.
I'm going to be in a Saint
Petersburg and then I'm going to on,
on Saturday we'll go into
the Florida gators first.
Lsu Mighty Lsu.
So I will be silent.
He rooting for, I like Florida too,
but I'll be rooting fella shoe man.
I can't fucking just cause they lost
to the sunbelt Trojans the fuck.
Um, but I get to go to
the legendary swamp and a,
I actually love both those teams,
but a,
I decided to hitch my wagon to Lsu so
I can't just like fucking jump. I, I,
you know, I'm not going to be
a con on either one of those.
I'm just going to be happy to
be at that legendary field, um,
the at the swamp and then
also to be at the, uh,
pirates of the Caribbean stadium stadium
that the Tampa Bay Buccaneers planned.
Um, all right. Lewis Hamilton
on HBO. Hey Bill. Big Fan.
Just wanted to let you know that Lewis
Hamilton is going to be featured on Hbo
Real Sports Tonight. I gotta watch that.
Uh, if you miss it, I'm sure you can. Uh,
I'm sure you can watch it later
on. Demand. Keep doing your thing.
Love F is for family and the
podcast is a weekly ritual for me.
Best wishes to you and your growing
family. Oh, thank you very much.
I'm going to allow to
try to check that out.
I saw I follow is Hamilton on
Twitter. And I saw that he, uh,
had some announcement to make and it
looked like was wearing some moto GP suit
and he was walking to a,
towards a motorcycle.
Now there's no fucking way the Mercedes
team is going to let them do that, right?
I don't think so.
So I don't know what the announcement was.
Maybe he'd said he got another diamond
stud for his other side. His knows,
I have no idea. I don't pretend to
live in that man's stratosphere.
I live in the troposphere. He lives
in the stratosphere. All right.
The Buccaneers logo,
everybody. A bullet built.
Uh, the original Buccaneers
logo was taking from the school.
I went to Beloit college.
They settled in court and Beloit one
because the school has been around before
the NFL.
Uh,
the school is big in the liberal arts
culture and the conversation of changing
the mascot due to the barbaric
history of the Buccaneers, uh,
the school actually has two
mascots in official and unofficial.
The unofficial is a turtle and they're
trying to see if they can make it the
official mascot over the
buccaneer. Good Lord. I could,
I could give a fuck about it.
But how would you feel if the Patriots
were to change to a pussy animal?
First of all, I fucking love turtles.
If you don't like turtles, man, this,
there's something wrong with you.
They're awesome. They don't bug anybody.
And if you think they're pussies,
go out and go get bit by one. Um,
I fucking love turtles.
I add one as a pet and I went to
church and I came home and it drowned.
Stain was Ralph and it buried it in the
fucking woods. I never got another one.
Uh, thanks for bringing
it up. Uh, anyways,
some pussy animal because
they're associated with white
nationalists or whatever.
Grotesques historical events
that is beyond our control. Um,
the funny thing about that is all the
liberal white people that go along with
doing that shit do not want to give up
their land or their flat screen TVs.
I get, you know, so as
a, as a a half assed,
you know, gesture, they're
going to get rid of the mascot.
Like obviously I feel the Redskins.
I mean it's literally like a racial slur.
So I get that one. But, uh, this
other shit, I mean, I dunno,
liberal people want to get rid of it,
but I feel that's kind of a way of, uh,
getting away with being conc is you're
kind of getting rid of the evidence.
You know, if they had the buccaneer
err on the side, they'll be like, well,
who's that? And be like, Oh yeah,
that was a group of white people that
came over here and just massacred a bunch
of fucking people. Just took a bunch
of shit. They were evil. They are evil.
And for all I know, uh, you
are one of their descendants,
but if you just make it all go away and
there's just a turtle, I don't know.
I think they give human
beings too much credit.
Like you have to understand that we're
kind of out of our fucking minds. Um,
some something, some of it has to do
with power. I don't know what it is, but,
uh, I dunno. We get too much power. You,
we behave like those fucking chimpanzees
when they go out and hunt the other
monkeys. You know what I mean? I'll never
fucking get over watching that. I just,
it's the human,
the way they get excited and the way
they torture the other fucking monkey
rather then just kill
the fucking thing is a,
is a level of like sit there.
That's why I don't like cats.
I don't like that.
They just won't kill the mouse.
How the fucking things freaking,
I just put it out of its fucking misery.
They want,
still want to have fun with it.
MMM.
Like if somebody said, we're
descendants of cats, I'd be like, yeah,
I fucking believe that.
Where are we sneaking up on each other?
Trying to stab one another,
you know? Um, anyways,
I respect cats though, you know, I respect
them all. I'm just saying, you know,
just that behaviors is fucking
weird. Anyways, he says,
love the fuck out of the podcast.
Been listening since 2011 and followed
your comedy sense. Why do I do this? Uh,
thank you for all the labs. Hope your
family's doing well and go fuck yourself.
Yeah, my baby girl had a little
bit of the sniffles do what?
A baby as a cold and it's sneezes.
That's the funniest shit ever.
They don't cover their mouth and just,
it's fucking unreal.
It's like poltergeist and uh, what's
that? What's that? Nickelodeon.
Slime. Um, so if you've got a baby, uh,
somebody told me this is good
advice was just to get like a,
a face cloth and have it wet and Dab at
it so you don't make their nose all raw
and all that stuff. Obviously
frequently rinse it out, change it.
I know this is disgusting, but it
was kind of what I was doing. Um,
I feel like I gave her the cold cause I
came back from Toronto and I felt like I
had s was fighting off something and
I'm not going to not hug and kiss.
My daughter does that. My daughter. Right.
So I was hanging out with her and, uh, Nia
was out with some friends this weekend,
so it was kind of a, I got to be the
single dad and I gotta tell you, man,
I fucking loved it.
You know,
I don't know what these single
parents are complaining about.
I did it for about eight hours and
I didn't have a problem at all.
No, it was awesome. We, she watched them,
the Formula One race with three
and she watched the Patriots game.
I got a patriots onesy um,
and they get said little but
awesome or something like that,
has the Patriot logo on it and
whenever it's football Sunday.
And what's cool is Nia is
not into sports and shit.
So she didn't want it to
have a bunch of sports shit,
but I just bought it anyways.
And uh,
she fought for like two
seconds. He's like, all right,
if you're into that, fine,
she gets it, she gets it. So that's what
it is. Football Sunday, I come home,
she's got two different patriots onesies.
I got to get her a Bruins one for the
season coming up and all it's playoff
baseball. Joe Bucket, his finest, um,
efforts for families.
Joe Buck at his finest.
I'm looking forward to that.
Crossing my fingers for a Yankees.
Red Sox match up another classic series.
Who knows who wins this, you know,
I don't know how many times we played this
year, but we were dead even, you know,
if we played 18 times, we
went nine and nine. Um,
and I got it to be interesting,
serious cause I haven't seen price be
able to beat the fucking Yankees at least
in the second half when I was
paying attention. So we'll see. Uh,
how many home runs did judge end up with
a love of the people that have given
him shit. I was so happy that he got
fucking 50. These fucking cops. Dude,
I'm telling you that they say that the
home run Derby fucks up your swing. Oh,
is that what they say? So what they
say? You're not a football scout.
Are you all right Aaron? Judge, all
fucking rise court is in session.
Have you reached a verdict? We get
it. His last name's judge Aaron.
Judge stats. Here we
go. I know we've got 50.
What did he finish with?
Hold on.
It's 50 fucking toe.
Holy Shit.
That is fucking amazing.
52 home runs.
I let everybody give him shit
about his strikeouts. Gives a fuck.
Yeah.
114 Rbis, hundred 27 base
on balls. 208 strikeouts.
52 home runs.
You had 542 at bats
and he had to, he still hit two 84 with
two oh 208 strikeouts. He still had to 84.
It's fucking amazing. What a season
graduations to him. I hope he beat you.
I hope you be. If we fucking,
you know what I'm, I, you know,
I'm not one of those carts
that can't recognize greatness.
That's fucking amazing. All
right, dear Billy button nose. Uh,
thought this was interesting.
A new French law says that photo's must
come with a disclaimer that they're
photo shopped. I love the French.
I fucking love the French.
You know what I mean?
You know why?
Cause they fucking going around having
threesomes and they're sick of being
excited about bringing somebody else into
their relationship and they don't look
like the fucking picture. You know
what I mean? I get it. Anyways.
It's being done to discourage unhealthy
extreme thinness among people trying to
emulate unrealistic body shapes that
were faked with the computer program.
All right, so I was a little
off the mark on that. Um,
this could really change the
landscape from models, right? There's,
is sports equivalent in there somewhere.
Uh,
love you love Nia, keep up
the good work. Um, yeah,
I mean I think that's probably, that's
not for adults. That's for more. Uh,
I think that's for kids. Um,
cause I noticed, you know,
when I went to Toronto I couldn't believe
how good looking the people went on.
And I've just been going around in general
just noticing how good looking people
are. And I was just like, what the fuck is
going on? And what I, I think it is, it's,
I think it's an a result of everybody
being on social media and you post a
picture yourself and you know,
all this stuff that you
didn't about yourself and
then shit that you didn't even
recognize that, that evidently people,
other people notice in comments,
you know, a dude, you fucking nice
new profile picture. But I got it.
Got to ask, okay, what's
up with your right ear?
What's up with that shirt? What's up
with the blah, blah, blah, you know,
and then it's unreal. And then you
start getting like a fucking complex.
Um,
social media is other than promoting.
Um, but anyways, I just feel
like for me, social media,
I promote gigs and I go on and I
try to make people laugh. That's it.
But to actually go on there and look at
comments, it's just not a healthy thing.
I don't think it's healthy for anybody.
Even if you're the most beautiful fucking
person in the world. Because you know,
at some point you're gonna start to go
down the other side and then the comments,
hey, you still hot, but you started to
look starting to show your age there.
Lol. Just kidding. You know, I love you.
That's all. Somebody who's gotten nothing,
nothing but fucking
compliments needs to hear,
and then it's just a downward spiral
into fucking botox and all of that shit.
Um, if I could promote anything, uh,
just fucking,
just acted goddamn age,
that's the best way to do it. Just
as you, as you're in your forties,
dress like you're in your forties,
keep yourself in good fucking shape.
There's a certain number you hit and
the best she can be at that point is you
look good for your age.
And if somebody says that to you,
it's a fucking compliment. You got to be
young. You weren't cheated. All right,
stop trying to fucking hang
on by your fingernails.
It's fucking over.
Let young people be young.
Let them have their,
whatever the fuck it is they're doing
with those Goddamn Djs. I don't get it,
but it's their shit.
Let them have it.
Stop showing up with your botox face
asking if anybody has any Molly.
Okay. You're creeping
people out. All right.
It's over. Mike. My public
service announcement is over.
All right. Apocalypse prep.
Hey Bill.
Recently my girlfriend got mad that I
don't have anything prepared in case of a
hurricane or a massive flood. I'm not
naive, but we live in Kansas City.
I told her that while I have a flashlight,
extra cases of water and a generator,
not bad for a 25 year old homeowner,
that's pretty fucking great.
Annual on a home, a 25.
Congratulations. Um,
I don't have a box titled Apocalypse Shit.
She said, I never think
about the future. Oh boy.
I told you know. Well, you know, at least
she's not asking for a kid. We made,
I don't think about the future. I
bought a house. You dizzy broad.
Uh, I told her that a gas
powered generator is literally
a symbol for the future.
Uh,
you talk about this stuff all the time,
but have you actually got anything ready?
Thanks.
Ps loved the music and the
throwbacks. Uh, well Andrew thumbless,
he's the one that picks out the
music. Um, I, I bought some shit.
I bought some bucket of fucking food
that, you know, would last forever.
And like the lid on the bucket,
um,
also doubled as a toilet seat
and you could shit in the bucket,
but then I don't know where
your food went. I went down
the rabbit hole, you know,
about 10 years ago, thinking
about, you know, uh,
going off the grid and fucking buying gold
and silver coins and all of this shit.
And then I was just, then I just went the
other way and I was just like, you know,
I don't think I want to
survive the apocalypse.
I'm fine if I'm laying in the street,
you know what I mean?
Cause then I would just live
this unbelievable quality life.
And then once the apocalypse
hit and everything sucked,
I wouldn't have to fucking live
through it. You know, you're like,
when I'll fucking player like a,
okay,
say like doc rivers. Like, you know,
he won a championship with the Celtics
and then they totally dismantled the team
and he's like, dude, I, I'm too fucking
old to go through a rebuilding year.
That's how I feel with like
society. Okay. It's just been great.
Every fucking day of my life.
Okay. Yeah. Just, you know.
Yeah.
My fucking dresser drawer is
full of championship rings.
I got to live in this country. Look
at how I looked. I fucking lucked out.
Not going to fucking lie to you. I lucked
out. So follow that shit goes away.
You know what I mean?
And everything just collapses.
And then fucking prisoners at car.
I'm not going to fucking survive that.
So that'll be it.
You know what I mean?
I'd fucking down a bottle of
booze and then just turn the,
I guess it's different now
that I got a family. I Dunno.
Maybe I'll buy a generator.
All right. Movie,
movie lines. I gave you one
this week. See She, she, uh,
did Billy Bass drum.
Uh,
this is the best line from a [inaudible]
could we talk bass drums here for a
second?
Everybody I know has a different fucking
way of tuning the Goddamn Bass Drum.
What is your, what is the way that you
do it? Do you get a good sound out of it?
I just had somebody blew my fucking mind
when I thought it was you just tuned
the batter head.
You know,
that was the one that I thought
you put a little tension too.
And then I thought the other side,
you just fucking, you know, just
yeah.
You know, tightened it. Pass the
wrinkle. Alright. Cause Hey, you want to,
you want to move that air, right?
You also want to have the, I dunno,
fuck the fucking beat or have
something to rebound off of. And uh,
then I met somebody and he fucking
tells me the exact opposite thing.
And then I met somebody this weekend
and he goes back the other way.
I don't know what the fuck to do.
All I know is my bass drum tuning sucks.
So, um, whatever, I'm going to give
it another shot. I'm just gonna.
You just have to have the balls to just,
just keep on doing it and doing it
back again and then just dealing with
whatever shit sound you'd
come up with an each time.
Hopefully getting it a
little bit better. But, uh,
I'm always open to listen to people.
Uh,
any ideas you have, please let me
know. All right, dear Billy Bass drum,
this is the best line from a supporting
character in a movie is from Wayne's
world too. There's nothing
vulgar so you can play it on air.
Wayne and Garth had brought a roadie back
from the UK to help put a concert put
on a concert while hanging out.
He tells them this crazy story,
rock and roll story about Ozzy, Jeff Beck
and Keith Richards. Give it a listen.
All right,
let's hope there's no fucking racial
slurs in this like there was last week.
Um,
or some reason the link isn't working.
Oh, well, I want the link work. Where
is it? Oh, you know what I need.
I have to go over here.
Hang on, I'll hit pause.
You don't have to torture your way through
this. All right, we're back. Here we go.
Here it is air. It is. Come on.
Go on
stage.
No one's going to be able to
hear this dude. I don't know why.
It's super fucking quiet.
What's going on here?
I got all the volumes up. Oh, I
know this thing. And that's when he,
in the end he said, uh, you know, he
goes into the store to go buy him.
You need to buy chocolate m and m's
to fill up into Ozzie's brandy glass.
And he goes there and the place was closed
and they had some dog fights off the
dog and then he had the murder, the
owners with their own shoes. Right.
I think that's what it is. I'm sorry dude.
I don't know if anybody can hear this.
Can you hear it?
Well, instead of this bloody
well
in the shop phone on his son,
different story all together.
All right.
To beat them to death.
There you go. Nasty businesses in
it. I never watched it. I know.
I never saw Wayne's world. That was
right when I started doing standup.
So I fucking missed out on it. I was
too busy trying to get on stage. Oh,
by the way,
the ticket link for the all things
comedy podcast festival is in Phoenix is
up@billboard.com for the first time ever.
I am going to do a live
Monday morning podcast.
Now the first thing is you asking yourself
as like, you're going to have a guest?
No.
Are you going to address the no,
I'm going to go out there.
I'm going to get a bed and I'm
just going to lay down in it.
You guys are fucking sit there and watch
it. I don't know if it's gonna work,
but we'll see. We'll see. It's
going to be more like a play.
It's going to have headphones on. I'm
going to block out people laughing. Um,
I'm probably,
I have to react to the crowd,
but I'm not going to be fucking going
out there doing stand up or any of that.
I'm going to sit down and I'm just going
to fucking do my boy. You're again.
You know, if you're just
going to be able to watch it.
I've got to have some sort
of commemorative tee shirt
or a poster or some shit,
but that is going down
in Phoenix, Arizona. He,
I've never done the video thing I did
at one time and it at the all things
comedy podcast,
I guess I did at one time,
but if you ever wanted to see what the
fuck this shit looks like, um, who knows?
Maybe it won't work.
Like rap, like rap live.
Remember when they
didn't know I'm I sorry.
Wrapped with a live band member that
when they tried to do that unplugged you
only guy who ever pulled it off was ll
cool j. He pulled it off. Everybody else.
It just never,
it just didn't fucking work.
You got to add the guy on the turntables.
Um,
I'm probably wrong about that, but I just
said it and I'm going to stick by it.
All right. Fat phobic.
Dear Billy Backbreaker,
I'm a 28 year old Hawaii
male living in Ohio.
I had been single for nearly
four years now. Congratulations.
I consider myself to be an active
guy. Rock climbing, going to the gym.
Is this like your Tinder fucking
bullshit you're sending me.
I like to rock climb, go to the
gym, cycling, et Cetera. Anyways,
I used to be overweight at 250 pounds
and over the course of a year I was able
to get down to 172 pounds and maintain
that to to the activeness and eating a
plant based diet. Good for
fucking you sir. Making me fall.
You're inspiring me. Good for you
man. What a great thing you did.
My situation is this.
I have some ladies that have expressed
their interest in me. However,
the majority of them are overweight and
have no self control when it comes to
their diet and exercise.
I'm not attracted to bigger women,
which puts me in a difficult situation
when they very openly flirt and invite me
out. Why? You're not attracted to them.
That's totally fine and it's totally
fine to not be into overweight people.
I don't know why.
You have to pretend that you're in
the people that you're not into,
so the person you know eating the
fucking Drake's cake can feel good about
themselves. What about you? There's
still a victim in there. Okay.
And considering being on a shape
is curable for most people.
I'm not saying it's not a disease,
but for most people they do what you do,
plant based Diet to get
active and fucking falls off.
Plus considering you are a fatty,
this is like an alcoholic,
you know who got sober,
you're going to go hang
out with an alcoholic.
I guarantee you will become a fat
fuck hanging out with them. Right?
And then where are you going to be?
You're going to be laying down
and she tries to ride you on top.
I hope you got enough to fucking still
get it in there to belly slapping
together. You don't have to
be part of that to you. Uh,
the ladies can turn down men no problem.
But when a man turns down a lady,
some of the ladies I work with in their
close friends, I've known for you.
Some of the ladies I work with in our
close friends I've known for years. Well,
why the fuck would you date them anyways?
They know that I've been single for
four years. Honestly, I am picking,
I've also learned to be happy after
multiple bad relationships. Dude,
you are fucking crushing life right now.
Don't fuck it up by dating some fatty
that you work with because society is
telling you that you're not
progressive if you don't. Anyways,
so when I deny a date requests
or don't flirt back with them,
they say that I'm fat phobic.
Is this, what if this has come to, um,
what gives some fat fucking
mantated Douche came walking
up to them pressing his
dick up against, I mean that's
what the fuck they're doing to you
sticking their fucking clam and your
face smelling like a Jim Dandy Sunday at
friendlies. Right? What the fuck?
Fuck off. I'm not fat phobic.
I just weighed 172 pounds and I know
that I can get a better fucking cut of
meat. I'm sorry, I didn't mean to go.
That means I'm just saying cause that
fat phobic pissed me off. All right,
you should respect
everybody. Just say, listen.
Um, I used to be fat like you
and I started rock climbing.
Why don't you rock climb?
Okay.
Or at least maybe just stare at a bunch
of rocks instead of eating rocky road
ice cream every fucking weekend
may be girl, throw your bang.
Every once in a while is dice clay
says, I'll trow you a bang. Yeah, dude,
can I tell you something right now,
this fucking woman's movement
thing is completely out of control.
It's completely out of control.
They are not all of them,
but so many of them are everything that
they're fucking preaching that they
don't want guys to do
to them. Okay? There,
you know you have the
absolute 100% right to date.
Whoever the fuck you want to date,
you have the right to be as
shallow as you fucking want to be.
You could date for looks for 10 fucking
years if you want to before you want to
settle down and get serious. You
know, and if you wait too long,
you're going to pay the price, but
it's your life. The linen. This is,
this is your fucking life,
dude.
You're going to date some fucking fatty
and you don't want to just so what the
those constant work, we'll
look at you in a better way. I,
I wouldn't do that. Just be like,
yeah, my dance card is full.
All right, this, these are
the measurements I like and
I'm not ashamed of it. Okay?
That's what I find attractive
as do you,
can I tell you something?
All of those women at work,
if they could be the size that
you find attractive would be,
you know what I mean?
And they ate their way into that position.
It's their job to eat the way out,
the same way you did.
So you had to get on a bike,
you had to climb a bunch of rocks,
you had to do all this shit. Now
your urine game shape, right?
You're fucking and Coby Bryan shape and
there's showing up like shack and they
want to try to play their way into shape.
Remember Colby still,
he's give chefs shit for doing that.
Yeah. Fuck that. Anyways, he says,
I've never pointed out their weight,
but when I have openly expressed interest
in other women while talking to the
other guys at work, the women start to
shame me. All right dude. You know what?
I was on your side until you said
shame. What do, what the fuck happened?
What happened to people?
They shame you.
You just fucking laugh at him saying that.
Only like bones and twigs.
Um,
I get along with everybody
so I never strike back.
What's your problem with anything in
fear that I might be taken to HR for God
knows what in days.
Also having denied some of the women
they've gone as far as to not speak to me
as much until other female co coworkers.
How horrible of a man I am.
Leaving them to have bad attitudes against
me just because I won't date them. Uh,
do what he looked like Burt Reynolds. What
the fuck's going on here? I would, uh,
yeah. Listen, this is the deal.
Women go to HR guys, just laugh
at it. So just laugh at it, dude.
You know what I would do? I would be
overly friendly to the ones that hate me.
You know, morning. So
you look lovely today.
Kill them with kindness,
and then I would bring the most smoking
hot fucking chick you can find to the
fucking Christmas party. That's what you
got to do anyways. He says it's true.
I'm not attracted to big a women. That's
fine. There's nothing wrong with that.
But women sit around all day talking
about guys having to be this tall,
have this fair, she'll
hair, wear these clothes.
But when a man has any sort of criteria,
we get shamed.
Do Stop saying that.
Okay?
Being shamed is totally within your own
power at the age that you're at. Okay?
If you're a fucking teenager or
younger, I get it. All right?
But at some point you gotta be
comfortable with how you look. Okay?
You've got to get comfortable with
yourself and then someone can't shame you
unless you actually did
something shameful. Yeah.
If he kicked the puppy across the room,
you know what I mean?
You don't want to be comfortable enough
with yourself that you can handle the
criticism and have it not affect. You
should feel shame. All right. Anyways,
he goes,
I'm writing to hopefully get your take
on the matter and hear what you would do
in this situation.
I will never see desiring of fit healthy
person who about their body as a bad
thing. No, you shouldn't.
And that's something that all people
should aspire to be fit and in shape,
healthier than they were yesterday.
As much as you can. I, you know,
obviously the aging process,
you're getting older every second
one step closer to the grave. Right.
But you know, in the meantime, yeah.
Uh, thanks for all the good laughs.
You and Nia are the friends. I wish
I had real life. That's so nice.
Have a good day. Go Fuck Yourself. Yeah,
Dude. By the way, that goes for women too.
Postal women too. All right. Um,
yeah,
yeah. Dave, what the fuck you want to
date? And if you want to be shallow.
Yeah.
You know, in dish date hot people than
just do that. See what that's like.
It's up to you. I don't understand.
You know what I mean? Like the,
you know what you have at work. Do you
have a bunch of busy bodies, you know,
and as these people out there
that want to be the person to say,
I introduced this person or that person,
um,
oh dude, I swear to God,
man, I swear to God,
you find the hottest fucking
chick you can fucking find.
You can fucking find. Take her to the
Goddamn Christmas party. And by the way,
let her know what's up.
Let her know what's up.
I would say I would find,
I would tell some fucking,
I would tell some hot chick that
whole fucking story and you know,
hot chicks loved being hot.
Nothing that they would make them feel
hotter than to go down there and have a
bunch of women look at or just hate
her because how fucking hace is.
There you go. Find that chick.
Maybe she's into sports too.
Next thing you know, you guys are
running the country, not the country.
That company.
That's perfect.
Ah, it's a fantasy. But maybe you can
make it happen, sir. I'm good luck to you.
Good luck to you. And uh,
that's it. And by the way,
there's plenty of guys out there that
like big women, you know what I mean?
It's plenty.
Yeah.
Did you get, it's up to you to be happy
with your own fucking body. All right.
I'm telling you,
telling you just fucking have a salad.
Have One fucking salad a day.
Start fucking working out.
Read up as much as you can on nutrition.
Try the best you can.
Eat the best food you can,
which is really difficult,
you know, so he could do
then. Other than that,
leave people alone and let them date.
Who the fuck they want to date? Um,
all right. That is the podcast
for this week. Go fuck yourselves.
And A, I'll give you my fucking pick
of the week on Thursday. That's it.
When I'm in Tampa. [inaudible]
Thursday night football. Oh God.
They're going to be wearing those
ugly under roof fucking jerseys.
What do they call them?
The a full court press jerseys.
Whatever the fuck they call them. All
right, that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.